[Music]  the WWE  you know the WWE sure you do cut 7% of  its staff and wrestlers 7% that's a big  chunk in order to meet its budget that's  right now the cuts included many  wrestlers who never quite caught on with  the public we invited some of those  fired wrestlers here tonight for a final  send-off they never really made it for  whatever reason say goodbye to Donnie  duct tape  [Music]  [Applause]  say hello to the Puerto Rican vegan he's  Puerto Rican he's a vegan  don't know why say hello to miracle Mike  it's a miracle ladies and gentlemen  [Applause]  hey hello ladies and gentlemen to the  iron recluse  [Applause]  that is stupid  say hello to lazy boy Reis he never  caught on  yeah  ladies and gentlemen say hello to the  rabid rabbi  and finally say farewell to Paco muchos  Gatos  [Applause]  that's quite a new sex  you